لقد كان يومًا مشمسًا مجيدًا لهذا
الكشف عن كل من هاري وويليام ، وقد شارك كل من هاري ووليام
بعمق في العملية برمتها التي
تعود إلى سنوات في تصميم
الحديقة التي أعيد تصميمها بالكامل
ولكن أيضًا التمثال نفسه
الذي وصلوا معًا كانوا يبتسمون
وكانوا يتحدثون أنهم كشفوا النقاب عن
التمثال
معًا في الحديقة التي اعتادوا
اللعب بها في مرحلة النمو
، وقد اعتبرته الأميرة ديانا مكانًا خاصًا جدًا ،
ولهذا
السبب سيقف التمثال الآن هنا
كإرث دائم لحياتها وعملها
في التمثال الذي تراه  إنها محاطة
بأطفال يشاركون بعمق في العديد
من المشاريع ،
فهم ليسوا أطفالًا محددين
يمثلون الأطفال الذين اعتادت على
العمل مع الجمهور ، وسيتمكنون من الذهاب
إلى قصر كنسينغتون ورؤية هذا
التمثال وهذا كثيرًا ما هاري
و  يريد ويليام المضي قدمًا ، هذا
هو الوجه
العام لديانا كيف يريدون أن
تتذكرها والصورة تم التقاطها بالفعل
من السنوات الأخيرة من حياتها عندما
كانت  شعرت بتمكين
ماكس فوستر سي إن إن كينسينجتون بالاس لندن